HAPPENS TO THIS BRAVE PUSH TO
ADVANCE LIFE IN A DIFFERENT TYPE
OF WALKOUT.
NOW FACEBOOK VERSUS
CONSERVATIVES.
IT IS A THEME WE DISCUSSED LAST
NIGHT WITH INTERNET STARS
DIAMOND AND SILK WHO GOT SOME
GOOD PRESS TODAY.
CAME UP ON CAPITOL HILL DURING
SENATOR TED CRUZ'S QUESTIONING
OF FACEBOOK CEO MARK ZUCKERBERG.
>> REPORTING THAT FACEBOOK HAD
PURPOSELY AND ROUTINELY
SUPPRESSED CONSERVATIVE STORIES
FROM TRENDING NEWS, HAS BLOCKED
THE POSTS OF A FOX NEWS
REPORTER, HAS BLOCKED OVER TWO
DOZEN CATHOLIC PAGES, AND MOST
RECENTLY BLOCKED TRUMP
SUPPORTERS DIAMOND AND SILK'S
PAGE WITH 1.2 MILLION FACEBOOK
FOLLOWERS AFTER DETERMINING
THEIR CONTENT AND BRAND WERE
"UNSAFE TO THE COMMUNITY."
ARE YOU AWARE OF ANY AD OR PAGE
THAT'S BEEN TAKEN DOWN FROM
PLANNED PARENTHOOD?
>> SENATOR, I AM NOT.
BUT LET ME SAY --
>> HOW ABOUT MoveOn.org?
>> I'M NOT SPECIFICALLY AWARE OF
THOSE.
>> HOW ABOUT ANY DEMOCRATIC
CANDIDATE?
>> I'M NOT SPECIFICALLY AWARE.
I'M NOT SURE.
>> Laura: JOINING ME FOR
REACTION IS JEFFREY LORD.
CONTINUING OUR "DEFENDING OUR
FIRST" SEGMENT.
I THOUGHT THAT WAS A GREAT
EXCHANGE.
HE WENT ON TO SAY THAT HE IS
CONCERNED BECAUSE SILICON VALLEY
IS VERY LEFT.
HE SAID IT'S A LEFT OF CENTER
PLACE AND THAT'S WHAT IT IS.
HE SAID WE ARE VERY CONCERNED
ABOUT PROTECTING AND ALLOWING
ALL VOICES ON THE FACEBOOK
FORUM.
BUT HE DIDN'T REALLY HAVE A GOOD
ANSWER TO CRUZ.
HE KIND OF MET HIS MATCH IN
TED CRUZ ABOUT ALL OF THESE
VOICES THAT ARE HAVING BEING
HEARD.
WHAT WAS YOUR REACTION TO THAT
EXCHANGE?
>> THIS IS WHAT CONCERNS ME.
SOMEONE ELSE ON THAT PANEL ASKED
HIM WHETHER OR NOT HE COULD
DISCUSS THE POLITICAL LEANINGS
OF HIS EMPLOYEES AND HE SAID
SOMETHING TO THE EFFECTIVE WELL,
HE DOESN'T CHECK.
THE POINT IS HE DOESN'T HAVE TO
CHECK THEM.
HE IS GETTING HIS EMPLOYEES FROM
A POOL OF PEOPLE THAT HE HIMSELF
SAYS ARE EXTREMELY LEFT-LEANING.
THAT'S WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN
HERE.
I HAVE TO LAUGH.
IT'S THE SAME ARGUMENT I WAS
HEARING WHEN I WAS A TEENAGER
FROM PEOPLE LIKE SPIRO AGNEW
EXCEPT IT WAS ABOUT THE
TECHNOLOGY OF THE DAY WHICH WAS
CBS, ABC, AND NBC.
IT'S THE SAME ARGUMENT TODAY
EXCEPT WE ARE DEALING WITH
FACEBOOK OR GOOGLE OR TWITTER.
IT DOESN'T CHANGE.
WHAT WE'RE DEALING WITH HERE ARE
PEOPLE WHO HAVE A LIBERAL BIAS
AND -- DIAMOND AND SILK.
I COULD NOT BELIEVE THAT.
I KNOW DIAMOND AND SILK.
THEY ARE FABULOUS PEOPLE.
THE NOTION THAT THEY ARE UNSAFE
FOR THE COMMUNITY.
THIS IS CRAZY.
THAT'S THE WAY THE LIBERAL MIND
WORKS.
THAT'S WHAT YOU GET.
>> Laura: WHEN THEY SAY
COMMUNITY --
>> THE QUESTION IS HOW DO WE
DEAL WITH IT.
>> Laura: EXACTLY.
WHEN THEY SAY COMMUNITY, THEY
MEAN THE LIBERAL COMMUNITY.
THEY ARE OFFENSIVE AND UNSAFE TO
THE LEFT WING MIND-SET DOMINATES
IN SILICON VALLEY AND MOST OF
CALIFORNIA.
THEY ARE VERY CONCERNED ABOUT IT
AND THEY ARE VERY CONCERNED
ABOUT IT CATCHING ON THROUGH
PERHAPS INCREASING POPULARITY OF
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
ZUCKERBERG, OBVIOUSLY HE'S A
REALLY SMART GUY BUT HE DID NOT
HAVE GOOD ANSWERS WHEN IT CAME
TO THOSE QUESTIONS OF WHY ARE
THESE EXAMPLES OF CONSERVATIVE
ORGANIZATIONS -- TED CRUZ RATTLE
THEM OFF, NOT GETTING ADEQUATE
RESPONSE ON FACEBOOK.
THEIR FOLLOWERS ARE NOT GETTING
THEIR NOTICES.
YOU GET A MUMBO-JUMBO ANSWER.
NOT A GOOD RESPONSE.
>> RIGHT.
WE NEED TO BE CANDID.
THE CASE OF DIAMOND AND SO, IF
THEY WERE AFRICAN-AMERICAN WOMEN
WHO WERE LIBERAL, NO ONE AT
FACEBOOK WOULD HAVE BLINKED WHEN
THEY POSTED SOMETHING.
THE FACT THAT THEY ARE
AFRICAN-AMERICAN WOMEN WHO LOVE
DONALD TRUMP, THAT'S NOT
SUPPOSED TO HAPPEN.
SO THEY HAVE TO BE CURBED.
THAT'S THE REAL PROBLEM.
>> Laura: WE DO WHAT DOC
>> Laura: WE DO WHAT DON
>> Laura: WE DO WHAT DOE
>> Laura: WE DO WHAT DOV
>> Laura: WE DO WHAT DOT
>> Laura: WE DO WHAT DOS
>> Laura: WE DO WHAT DOD
>> Laura: WE DO WHAT DO?
WE ARE CONCERNED ABOUT DEFENDING
FREE EXPRESSION, FREEDOM OF
CONSCIENCE, THE FIRST AMENDMENT.
THESE CORPORATIONS ARE SO BIG.
THEY ARE LIKE MANY GOVERNMENTS.
THEY CAN CONTROL, KEEP OUT.
WHAT DO CONSERVATIVES DO?
DO THEY STOP USING FACEBOOK?
JUST D LIST?
>> I HATE TO GO THAT ROUTE.
I DON'T LIKE IT THE BOYCOTTS AND
ALL OF THIS.
I SPOKE TO A ADVERTISER WHO WAS
BOYCOTTED SEVERAL YEARS AGO BY
PEOPLE WHO DIDN'T LIKE RUSH
LIMBAUGH.
HE SAID TO ME THIS IS NOT A
BOYCOTT.
THIS WAS AN ORGANIZED TERROR
CAMPAIGN.
HIS LIFE WAS THREATENED.
HIS BUSINESS WAS THREATENED.
HIS EMPLOYEES WERE HARASSED.
>> Laura: IF CONSERVATIVES
WANT TO BE PART OF THE SOCIAL
MEDIA SYSTEM, THEY WANT TO BE
PART OF IT, IT'S IMPORTANT FOR
CONNECTING WITH FRIENDS OR
ADVANCING YOUR PRODUCT LINE OR
WHATEVER.
FACEBOOK IS STILL REALLY
IMPORTANT.
SO IS INSTAGRAM, SO IS SNAPCHAT
AND ALL THE OTHER MEANS OF
COMMUNICATION.
WHAT DO YOU DO?
>> YOU'VE GOT TO, HE GOT A
QUESTION TODAY ABOUT WHO WAS HIS
COMPETITION.
EFFECTIVELY THE ANSWER WAS HE
DOESN'T HAVE ANY.
I WOULD CERTAINLY HOPE THERE ARE
CONSERVATIVES OUT THERE WHO ARE
YOUNG AND ENTERPRISING AND
ENTREPRENEURIAL MINDED TO
CHALLENGE THIS.
THAT CERTAINLY CAN BE DONE OVER
TIME.
OTHER THAN THAT AT THE MOMENT, I
THINK YOU ARE SERIOUS HERE ON
DEFENDING THE FIRST IS
EXCELLENT.
WE'VE GOT TO PUBLICIZE IT.
GET THE WORD OUT WHETHER IT'S ON
TELEVISION OR THE INTERNET OR
PRINT AND LET PEOPLE KNOW HOW
THIS GAME IS WORKING.
IT'S NOT A GOOD ONE.
>> Laura: I THINK THAT'S
RIGHT.
LET'S TAKE ZUCKERBERG AT HIS
WORD.
HE WANTS ALL VOICES TO BE HEARD.